you might recall that there was a block  on the m25 not that long ago well they  have blocked parts of the m25  for the second time in three days  insulate britain is demanding government  action on home insulation  uh well the organization has stopped  traffic at several sections of britain's  busiest motorway it wrote on twitter  hashtag insulate britain are back boris  johnson can you hear us yet uh there  were two demonstrations junction 23 at  south mims in hertfordshire at junction  8 at ryergate to junction 9 at  leatherhead of course those in surrey  demonstrators sat on the road causing  huge queues of traffic insulate britain  said 89 of its members are taking part  demanding action on insulating homes